I've worked with Miz Cracker,
we did her finale look for 'Drag Race.'
Madonna, I've worked with her
since I was like 22 years old.
Nicki Minaj, Amanda Lepore, Lady Bunny,
and another wonderful queen
that I work with is Miss Fame.
I did a lot of her finale looks.
We are a custom design studio.
We pretty much create
anything from stage wear
to couture, to bridal, to gloves, hats,
it's pretty much a place
where anything is possible.
I would say anything from burlesque,
to special effects, to movies, television,
high fashion, couture, to anything
that you could wrap your head around
and just make fabulous, that's our niche.
We will use anything
from the most delicate
lace, to the stiffest
leather or molded plastic.
All sorts of just like, synthetics,
because if you're doing burlesque,
you're going to be dropping
that thing on the floor nonstop,
and you better be able to clean it.
The things that inspire my work,
the first thing is the person
that I'm designing around.
I take their essence, and then
I bring in where I come from
and I get a lot of my inspiration from
sci-fi, growing up with sci-fi as a kid.
Nature never gets it wrong,
which leads me to architecture,
which is derived from nature.
Fauna, dinosaurs, you name it,
I can be inspired by the
shape of a light bulb.
One of my favorite things
are tear away looks.
My technique is usually to
make the most unexpected
thing come off, or the
person just pulls one
little cord, and the entire
thing just peels away
to a completely other
look that's underneath it.
This is for a burlesque
performer named Eden Berlin,
and I just loved it so much because I was
thinking of some sort of
flora from outer space
and I really wanted her to reveal herself,
and slowly spin and just
like be blooming out of
this insanely gray
thing, and just sparkle.
And then there's layer after
layer after layer under this.
One of the most
challenging burlesque looks
that I've done as of late is Gin Minsky,
one of my favorite
clients, she wanted to be
a soft serve ice cream cone that peeled
out of an actual physical ice cream cone.
Had a waffle wrap, she comes
out of her waffle wrap,
she continues to take things
off, amazing the audience
until she ends up in
nothing but what looks
like melted pasties and a G string.
As much as I love to do stage wear
and insane costumes, I would love to make
it accessible to everybody out there.
If you feel like dressing
like a wasp woman,
or what have you, one day, we're all going
to be able to dress
however we feel inside.
That will be my time to shine.